today we're going to be solving a
trigonometric equation it's this one
that you can see right here
and i actually solved this exact
question a few days ago
in my class and i left that experience a
little bit dissatisfied because
the method that i know i'm comfortable
with and that most textbooks recommend
i know is actually pretty confusing and
this is what it looks like for those of
you who haven't seen it
you start with this question here and
you have to modify the domain that's
been provided so this is the domain
that gets stated in the question but in
order to translate that domain into
something useful for solving the
question
you kind of have to muck about with it a
little bit and then you use your
knowledge of normally solving
trigonometric equations to get some
angles
and then modify them and you end up with
these two solutions out the end
but it is far from intuitive it's a
pretty challenging method and one of the
things that i offhandedly said during
that lesson was
there are other ways to solve this
question now
i stand by using this method i think
that it's worth wrapping your head
around
and if you get it explained to you a
little more slowly you can actually see
how the pieces fit together more
comfortably
but i am going to show you another way
of doing this
because i looked at this question more
closely and i realized it had some
particular characteristics
that mean you have access to a bunch of
different tools
that you can use to solve it now it's
not the way that i would recommend
particularly for an advanced student
because you actually need some extension
one techniques to do it
and even if you're an extension one
student i would recommend that you do it
the other way because this is as you'll
see a much longer
way to do it and because it's longer and
it uses a lot of different knowledge
and that also makes it more error-prone
but it is one of the most important
things in mathematics to know you can
solve
one problem in multiple different ways
that's kind of um
sometimes what you gain insight from you
look at the same object from more than
one perspective
and then it helps you understand that
object so what we're going to do
is we're going to tackle this particular
question
using two extra techniques number one
we're going to think about this using
some trigonometric identities that we
have access to
through the extension one course and
then we're going to have to deal with a
quadratic equation you might look at
this question right now and think where
is the quadratic equation in here
well it will emerge and we'll have to
deal with it so
let's have a go at this together the
first thing i'm going to say is that i
actually have access to
a trigonometric identity that allows me
to deal with
the fact that this is what we call a
compound angle so you've got
sine of but then the thing that angle
being provided has um lots of different
pieces to it there's the
there's the two multiplying by the x and
then there's that pi on three which
introduce a phase shift so
how can we interact with that well the
relevant trigonometric identity here
is that when you've got sine of a
compound angle like a
plus b so you can see two components
there you can expand that into
sine a cos b
plus cos a sine b and there are some
nice
proofs for that that i've done before
you can find on the internet so if we
use this result
with our particular compound angle here
sine of 2x
plus pi and 3 what do we actually get
well i'll just maybe i'll put this here
so we can actually do it directly
underneath
i can say sine of 2x
plus pi on 3 is going to be equal to and
then i just do a straight substitution
where
i'm viewing 2x as my a and pi on 3
as my b so what we end up with is
sine of 2x
cos of pi on 3 plus
cos of 2x sine
of pi on 3. so this is the identity that
i can use and because i'm solving an
equation
with this sine of 2x plus pi on 3 on it
what i can do is i can just use this
whole right hand side
and use that to substitute what i had on
the left hand side so
let's get a copy of that apparently that
is equal to a half and i'm solving
with this particular domain from naught
to pi now one of the attractions of this
method that i'm about to show you even
though it is much longer than the other
way
is that in the previous method i had to
kind of deal with
the domain restriction this naught
to pi restriction i had to deal with it
first and i had to deal with it in a way
that makes you kind of think like
why am i doing this it's a bit
counter-intuitive it does give you the
right answer
but it isn't immediately apparent why
you're doing it now one of the great
things about this method is
you can leave that domain restriction
right until the very end we will
address it afterwards and it will be
much more common sense it will sort of
be reasonable why we're doing it at that
point for now though we've sort of
created a mess right we've
made this out of this much simpler term
this is expanded out but
because the particular angles involved
2x and pi on 3
i can work with each of those using more
trig expansions which i'm about to write
down in a second
and also some of my exact values because
pi on 3 i know what cos pi m3 and sine
pi on 3
are in exact terms so how do we deal
with this well
a couple of pieces let's deal with the
exact values first because then i can
just start to
evaluate them and look much simpler i've
got this sine
2x hanging out the front and then cos of
pi on 3 or cos of 60 degrees if you're
more comfortable
in that uh frame of thinking that's a
half so i've got that
evaluated then i have cos 2 x
sine of pi on 3 is root 3 on 2 and that
equals
a half so immediately you're like oh
this is already nicer because
once i've evaluated those exact values i
can
double everything on the left inside the
right hand side and then i get with my
fractions so
what that leaves me with if i multiply
left and right hand side by 2
i'm going to end up with sine of 2x plus
that root 3. i'll bring it out the front
cos of 2x
and because i've multiplied the right
hand side by 2 as well i just get 1.
okay great so i dealt with my exact
values at this point i now want to think
about well how do i deal with how do i
deal with these guys
and with trigonometric identities there
are so many different paths you can take
through this but
certainly for me the most immediate one
was to say
well i know what sine 2x is i have an
identity for that
it's our 2 sine x cos x and i can also
do a similar
replacement for cos 2x there's another
identity for this
which is cos squared x minus sine
squared x so both of these are the
double angle identities that we learned
in the extension 1 course
so i'm just going to do a straight
substitution with each of these and see
what i end up with
so i'm going to have 2 sine x cos x
over here and then i've got my root
3 cos squared minus
sine squared
and that equals 1. okay let's get those
equal signs a bit more whoopsie daisy a
bit more lined up because that's
slightly bothering me okay very good so
you can see what i've got here now is um
well i'm getting a quadratic this is why
i mentioned before and i kind of
knew i was going to end up with
something like this when i looked at the
original question and i saw oh there's
some double angle involved so the
identities that i'm
most likely going to be using lead me to
this quadratic
in um in a trigonometric function so
then what do i do with this
well our normal strategy is we want to
get everything in terms of a single
trigonometric identity right now i have
sines and cosines flying around
and one of the handy tricks that we we
can learn is that if you divide
everything through by an appropriate
trigonometric identity
then you can turn all these sines and
cosines into just a single kind
of trig function and so what i'm going
to do is even though it looks
like where did i get this from i'm going
to divide everything through
by cos squared x you might wonder why i
chose that well it's going to become
very apparent once i actually do the
division so
you can see i'm dividing every single
term and you've got to be careful you
don't miss any
i'm dividing them all through by cos
squared x and then let's see what we
emerge
or what we get at the end so for
starters over here on the first term you
can actually see
this cosine on the top will cancel with
one of the cosines on the bottom
you can see in the middle term you've
got cos squared on
cos squared so you're just going to get
1 out of that
sine squared on cos squared i think we
know what to do with that guy and then
we'll also have a reciprocal identity on
the right hand side so let's start to
write the next line
so 2 sine x on cos x which is what you
can see over here
that's 2 tan x right
then you've got root 3 which is still
there
we already decided that cos squared on
cos squared will cancel
sine squared on cos squared will give me
minus
tan squared and then on the right hand
side
one over cos squared the relevant
reciprocal identity here is
sec squared okay
now i need to pull in another identity
at this point because you're looking
thinking
wow um you created an equation with
two different kinds of trig functions
tan and sec
but that's what you started with you had
sines and cosines before right like so
how is this better
and the answer is using the pythagorean
identity which is sine
squared plus cos squared equals 1.
i can actually do that same trick that i
just did which is divide everything
through by cos
squared and you can see that it creates
a relationship not just between
sine and cosine but the two
trigonometric identities that i've ended
up with right so you get here
from this identity tan squared plus one
equals
sec squared so you can see i can
substitute that on the right hand side
so let's go ahead and do it
what have i got here well nothing is
going to change on the
left hand side yeah actually you know
what i can change this because i know
i'm going to go here eventually i'm
going to expand out
this this little set of brackets here so
i'll get my 210x
hanging out the front root 3 times 1 is
just the root 3
and then minus root 3
tan squared x okay that looks good
and then over here on the right hand
side instead of sec squared i'm going to
write
tan squared x plus 1 because you can see
that's what i get out of the pythagorean
identity so tan
squared x plus 1. okay
so you might look at this thinking it is
a bit of a mess
that's true but at least it's a mess
that i can deal with because
everything's in terms of a single
trigonometric um
term which is which is tan right
achinomex function i should say
so all i need to do here is sort of tidy
this up a little bit and then see if i
can put it into a form that's easier to
work with
so let's have a look i've got some tan
squared terms
i'm going to highlight them here so
there's that tan squared term and
there's that one there
i also have what's a good color i've got
a tan x term so just a single
tan x and then i also have a constant
term
it's over here in the root three that's
an irrational part and then there's a
one hanging over there okay so you can
see i've got a quadratic
in tan x i need to get everything on one
side so i can deal with it so
what's the best way to do this well i
think to avoid negatives
what i'm going to do is i will add root
3
tan squared x to both sides in fact i
want to get everything
over here on the right hand side okay so
what i'm going to get
with my tan squared x terms is
tan squared x there's the one
from there i'm going to add the root 3
tan squared x that's from here
i want to get the 2 tan x term on that
side as well so i'm going to subtract
2 10 x from both sides
and then i'll subtract root 3 from both
sides so that will give me one minus
root three so this is what i would
actually get on the
on the right hand side i've run out of
space you can see there's why i've
written it
on in sort of in the middle but actually
what i end up with on the other side
is is nothing i've gotten everything
together on on this right hand side
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
leave that on the left and i'm going to
say it's equal to
0. okay great so just to make sure you
can see how i've done this
my constant term is hanging out here
my tan x term
is there there's minus 2 10 x and then
you can see
my tan squared x terms are over here
so you can see how i've collected
everything from the previous line
okay now to make things ultra clear with
my quadratic i can do one more step
which is just to clean up
the tan squared and the tan and the
constants let me just separate them out
so when i factor out excuse me tan
squared x
what i'll get is one plus root
3 and then i get a tan squared
then i've got this minus 210 x that was
a really messy n
let's rewrite that and then just to make
it super obvious i'm going to put this
constant term the 1 and minus 3
3 really are one number together
that equals 0.